la guerra en Ucrania ha tenido
consecuencias para cientos de miles de
niños ucranianos y no solamente aquellos
que han sido heridos Durante los
enfrentamientos o los ataques sino
también para aquellos que ya tenían
enfermedades crónicas o niños incluso
que han nacido durante estos últimos 11
meses y que han tenido dificultades para
recibir tratamientos la guerra tuvo un
gran impacto en su condición mental y
psicológica él no era así antes de la
invasión no tenía miedo no era agresivo
ahora llora con frecuencia y en
cualquier momento de tensión o de crisis
empieza a llorar a gritar Por eso está
hospitalizado pero no era hacia un test
los doctores de este hospital dicen que
más allá de las heridas físicas o de las
grandes enfermedades que han surgido o
que se han hecho aún más crónicas en
mucho de los niños desde el comienzo de
la guerra al mayor efecto ha estado en
su parte psicológica y no solamente en
los críos sino también en sus madres que
han tenido que hacer un gran esfuerzo
para apoyarlos la situación se ha hecho
más dura para mí con los apagones porque
no puedo planear mi tiempo su condición
de salud obliga que lo tengo que
alimentar a una hora específica pero
cuando cortan la electricidad no puedo
cocinar y tampoco Puedo licuar la comida
Esto hace que muchas veces me toque
comprar comida preparada que no es buena
para él
ella tiene problemas para alimentarse
ahora estamos haciendo rehabilitación
para que respire bien por qué también
tiene problemas con eso para que pueda
toser por su cuenta y que el líquido en
sus pulmones pueda salir Por eso
empezamos con estos ejercicios físicos
Sony es uno de los miles de niños que
han nacido en Ucrania durante la Guerra
en su caso nació con problemas en el
cerebro que también han tenido
repercusiones en su sistema respiratorio
y desde que nació está recluida en este
hospital pero ella tiene la fortuna sin
embargo de estar en que miles de otros
niños ucranianos han estado en otras
regiones del país con mucho menor acceso
al servicio de hospital y al tratamiento